welcome everybody and thank you for
joining us for today's session on
pioneering understanding of the human
brain throughout the day today we will
be privy to the most up-to-date research
issues and innovations and our quest to
understand human brain function this
session is par excellence due to the
participation of brain initiative we
begin today with a scientific updates
track which will bring us Oklahoma with
the latest progress in the research on
humans division of brain the innovative
neurotechnologies track will showcase
supreme cutting-edge innovations which
will foster a dynamic understanding of
brain function and provide new hope to
patients will have important discussions
and hear from top experts on the ethics
of using such technologies and the
impacts of our advancements to ensure
that these objectives continue with best
practices in the nerve ethics track
finally we'll round out the day by
hearing from clinician scientists on how
the application of the latest known
technologies benefits patients now while
laying the groundwork for include
improved healthcare and personalized
medicine in the future in clinical
updates and now it is an honor and a
pleasure to introduce the person who
launched today's momentous session dr.
Joshua Gordon dr. Gordon is the director
of the National Institute of Mental
Health
he received an MD PhD degree at the
University of California San Francisco
and completed his psychiatry residency
and research fellowship at Columbia
University he joined the Columbia
faculty in 2004 and remained there until
2016 when he took over as director of
the NIH during that time he also had a
private practice was an attending at the
New York Presbyterian Hospital and was
the director of neuroscience education
at New York State Psychiatric Institute
dr. Gordon's work has been recognized by
several prestigious awards including the
brain and behavior Research Foundation
our sun-young
investigator award the rising star award
from the International Mental Health
Research Organisation the eighty Bennett
research award from the Society of
Biological Psychiatry
at the Daniel E Efron research awards
from the American College of
neuropsychopharmacology for a complete
biography on dr. Gordon please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
dr. Gordon's talk today is entitled
updates from the NIH brain initiative my
name is dr. Rushton a crush on you and I
will be our moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
words we would like to extend our
special thanks to the brain initiative
program directors and in particular dr.
James Knapp for their efforts in
organizing today's session before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting questions during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located at the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions following his
presentation this presentation is
educational and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your grants
and now without any further ado please
join me in welcoming our keynote speaker
dr. Joshua Gordon hi Thank You dr.
Sherman I appreciate the introduction
and appreciate the opportunity to talk
to you all about the NIH brain
initiative I'm gonna I'm really here on
behalf of a whole number of staff at the
National Institutes of Health and indeed
across government that has been working
diligently on the brain initiative since
its its inception about six years ago
the brain initiative organization is run
Nam
by myself and dr. Walter Cora chefs who
is the director of the National
Institute neurologic disease and stroke
and we serve as co-chairs of a Board of
NIH Institute directors but of course
the NIH the the brain initiative itself
is bigger than just the NIH I'll be
focusing mostly on the NIH portion but
we'll discuss interactions with other
government agencies and indeed
international brain initiatives towards
the end of my talk what is the brain
initiative the brain initiative is an
attempt to see the circuits of the brain
in action to try to understand how those
circuits control how we move plan
execute remember in a moat and otherwise
perform all the functions that we do as
human beings but in order to see those
circuits in action and understand how
they control our behavior we need to
develop novel technologies we need to
develop these technologies that will
help us monitor and manipulate circuits
monitor them to figure out how they work
and manipulate them to improve function
in case of disease we also need to
develop these technologies in order to
understand how disordered brain circuits
cause neurological psychiatric and
substance use disorders the brain
initiative was started as I said about
six years ago by an by the President
Obama at the time and it was immediately
taken up by many agencies within the US
government and indeed private entities
as well the first thing that had to
happen when the brain that should have
started was we need to develop a plan so
in 2013 the President Obama's Office of
Science and Technology Policy created a
work group with the help of the NIH
director dr. Francis Collins and his
Advisory Council that work
set-out developing a scientific vision
that vision essentially created a plan
that was divided into the first five
years of the brain initiative as
delineated by the vision which was
titled brain 2025 the first five years
were meant to emphasize technology
development the second five years were
meant to emphasize discovery driven
science using those technologies we've
actually done a fairly decent job of
getting things started I'll tell you
about that today
and then I'll talk about how we're how
we're strategizing the pivot from
technology development to discovery
driven science as we approach the real
halfway point of a ten year period from
2015 to 2025 of course the brain
initiative would have amounted to not
much at all were it not for the
commitment on the part of Congress to
fund the initiative the initiative
started out with modest funding but over
the past five years that funding has
increased to the point where in this
fiscal year fiscal year 2019 we have
about four hundred and thirty million
dollars a year to spend and that budget
has been committed through 2026 that
430,000 30 million dollars if I said
throughout thousand four hundred and
thirty million dollars to said that that
budget has been committed as I said
through 2026 and also importantly it
meets actually the recommendations for
the budget for the brain initiative set
forth in the 2025 document those funds
are meant to be distributed across a
range of different areas
everything from discovering the various
cell types of the brain from developing
tools to interrogate those cells and the
circuits they compose to developing
novel tools and methods in human ma
human imaging and modulation of neural
activity in human beings as well as more
granular methods to look at neural
recording and modulation and model
organisms tools and processes to use
them in order to develop a better
understanding of the neural circuits
themselves and then three overarching
components of the brain initiative a
training and dissemination component we
recognize that we need to be able to
train the next generation of scientists
to continue developing these tools and
even more importantly to use them we
need to disseminate these technologies
so that they are broadly available in
neuroscience community then a second
overarching area of data coordination
and informatics which were really just
getting started
we intend that all the data gathered
through the brain initiative be shared
and in fact we have been given authority
by Congress to require such sharing and
as of next spring any submitted brain
grant will have to promise to share all
the data from that grant as well as the
software used to analyze that data
through the networks that we're
constructing the brain initiative and
the third overarching area is
neuroethics we recognize that many of
these technologies when applied to human
beings or even to animals for that
matter raise novel neuro ethical ethical
issues that need to be addressed
particularly as these technologies move
into the dissemination phase so that's
the overview of the budget and what
we're spending it on as I said the
budget has been committed through 2026
and you can see this in this next slide
the total committed by Congress to the
brain initiative is about four point
nine billion dollars which represents as
I said something close to what was
recommended by the 2025 vision which was
four hundred million to five hundred
million dollars a year for ten years we
have given out importantly much less
than half of that total in the first
five years of the brain initiative for
2014
20:18 which means with the best is yet
to come and there's lots of
opportunities to continue the rapid
development of technology that we've
initiated and importantly to disseminate
that technology and implemented
throughout the neuroscience community we
recognize of course that as we approach
2020 which is the normal halfway point
of the initiative that we need to
examine the progress so far and
determine what the best ways forward are
to build on that progress and while the
scientific vision delineated in brain
2025 still guides us and we imagine will
continue to guide us through 2025 or
2026 when that funding when that funding
ends but but we also recognize that we
need to reconsider it and so about a
year ago dr. Collins the NIH director
reconvening
a new working group to to take a look at
the goals of the scientific vision
delineating
in 2013 and figure out how we how we
need to tweak them what couples can be
expanded because we've made more
aggressive progress than we anticipated
and what goals we haven't made so much
progress on so that we need to we need
to reconsider our approaches and then
finally what new things can we imagine
doing now that we couldn't have imagined
five years ago that that we should be
thinking about as we push towards 2025
and I'll have more to say about that
workgroup in a few moments these are
again the seven areas of focus of the
brain initiative the first tools for
cells and circuits and well first let me
say and in each one we have a number of
funding opportunity announcements that
are open for individuals to submit
grants to and of course in each one we
also have active grant programs and I'll
show you some of
the advances that many of these programs
have resulted in just to give you a
flavor for what we've been able to do
with the brain initiative funds at the
level of the NIH I should mention that
although this strategic vision serves to
guide more than the NIH I'm really going
to focus on the products and progress
that resulted from NIH grants they're
important contributions to the brain
initiative made by agencies like DARPA
the Defense Advanced Research technology
and Technology Administration as well as
the National Science Foundation and I'll
more to say on those partners and others
towards the end of the talk so the first
area the cell diversity and tools for
cells and circuits focus has five
funding opportunity announcements up and
really these focus on technologies that
will allow us to understand what are the
building blocks of the brain and where
are those building blocks so for example
we've launched a major initiative called
the brain initiative cell census Network
which seeks to catalogue all the types
of cells there are in the brain both
neural cells and non neural cells and
figure out the diversity not only brain
wide but also region by region and it's
really tasked with building a
three-dimensional atlas of the brain we
have a number of funding opportunity
announcements in advanced technologies
for no recording modulation and
stimulation and this really focuses on
primarily on model organisms and on
human beings in model organisms brain
initiative investigators have
constructed technologies that allow us
to monitor thousands tens of thousands
of neurons at the same time whether it
be electrically or optically they've
developed technologies to be able to
modulate specific neurons at specific
moments in time and in specific spatial
temporal patterns and novel
jeez that have the potential to be used
non-invasively in humans to give you
some of that same cellular specificity
like ultrasound coupled with mediators
that might be expressed in cell specific
passion pat patterns on the neural
imaging front which is a major component
of this advanced technologies in neural
imaging are given not giving us greater
specificity and in the brain stimulation
front as I'll show it in later on in the
talk we do brain initiative
investigators are developing closed-loop
stimulation paradigms for example that
allow greater control over symptoms such
as tremor in patients and Parkinson's
disease and in benign essential tremor
that really hold out the promise to
bring a new age of deep brain
stimulation to bear on clinical problems
each of the other areas has a number of
active funding opportunity announcements
I'll just point out a couple more in the
understanding neural circuits area we're
trying to encourage collaborations
between labs to use the technologies
that are developed in the previous two
areas to fully delineate the structure
and function of individual nurse certain
neural circuits that are responsible for
generating specific behaviors we're
really open in terms of the circuits
that are being used and one area that we
really hope to see some progress in or
the circuits that control the expression
of pain this is obviously an area of
great clinical need and it's an area
that's often neglected in neuroscience
and we don't really have a good handle
on particularly in the central circuits
involved in pain control and so we're
hoping to make some progress there and
we have a specific announcement out to
ensure that people understand that just
because we are the brain initiative is
focused on technology development
understanding neural circuits it doesn't
mean that you can't exploit them to
study circuits of clinical relevance I
should also mention one more that I
didn't
before which is that we have a funding
opportunity announcement at the bottom
of the page for small businesses to use
brain funds to develop further develop
these technologies and commercialize
them as one pathway towards
dissemination although there are
certainly others that we are supporting
I mentioned the brain initiative cell
sense of senses Network again the goal
of that network is to provide a
comprehensive reference atlas of all the
different cell types in the human monkey
and mouse brain and to understand that
brain by brain but also region by region
and area by area and eventually to
understand how those cell types assemble
into specific circuits we've invested in
a number of different projects that
total about two hundred and fifty
million dollars to be invested over the
next five years
these funded projects will support a
brain cell data center that will
aggregate the data from all the projects
make them publicly available in a usable
interface a print mouse brain cell
census center that focuses on
establishing all the brain types for the
mouse brain as well as a brain cell
census collaboratory an opportunity for
the various investigators were carrying
out these projects to work together
collaboratively to match the results
across labs and then a similar
collaboratory for human and non-human
primate brain cell censuses which for
now anyway are focused on specific parts
of those of those organisms brains but
will eventually hopefully achieve the
full brain scale that we are currently
achieving with the mouse brain cell
census the anticipated outcomes of this
brain initiative cell census are and the
essential knowledge of the diverse cell
types of the brain and really crucially
they're 3d organization within the brain
maybe the goal of the census network is
to create an open-access 3d digital
mouse brain cell reference atlas that
you'll be able to poke and prod and find
out
where are the different cell types which
brain regions where do they project to
etc that we will yield a comprehensive
neural circuit diagram for the mouse
brain the eventual goal that we hope to
achieve through the brain initiative is
to create the same kind of atlas for the
human brain and for the non for at least
to non-human primate species but first
we need to figure out how to do this on
a smaller scale and the mouse is the
model for that this atlas will be
tremendously useful for neuro scientists
studying the mouse and indeed studying
other organisms as well to have
established a complete circuit diagram
with all the component parts will be
kind of like having the human genome
sequenced we will know the players will
know the size of the field the details
will be important we'll need to really
truly understand not just what cell
types there are but how they change with
activity how they change through
development etc but the first start of
characterizing an atlas of all the
components of the brain is an important
one and that's the main goal of the BI
CCN what does it take to build such an
atlas it takes an understanding of the
shapes of the brain the morphometry of
it
it requires a ability to position
compartments in relation to other in
relation to the various components of
not just the neural structures of the
brain but the neurovascular units
requires a knowledge of the anatomical
projections of dendrites and axons in
both inputs and outputs of brain regions
it does require some understanding and
developmental migration particularly if
we are to be able to integrate an atlas
with development with what we know about
development and eventually create
developmental atlases as well but it
also requires an understanding of the
cell properties themselves the molecular
property properties there transcriptomes
there proteomes
but also the physiological properties of
those cells passive membrane properties
the compliments of ion channels and
neurotransmitters they use the receptors
that they have and and then finally of
we don't just want an anatomical atlas
we want an atlas that we can build over
time a functional component to that is
what the role of those circuit
components are in activity and how they
change based upon what based upon the
history of the organism in the history
of the brain so what we're creating is a
structure that initially will be it cell
type and anatomical and some physiology
but that we can add to and build to over
time so that eventually it's really a
truly comprehensive encyclopedia of the
knowledge that we have about the
components of the brain and how they how
they generate and related to behavior
how they change over time what's our
vision for the time frame for this cell
census well the first grants are
actually complete they were pilot grants
that were aimed at developing the
technologies to be able to create this
cell census this cell atlas and that was
completed in 2016 and and what surprised
us was that the rapidity with which
novel technologies were developed
particularly single cell technology such
as drop seek for transcriptomics but
also single cell single cell epigenetics
and other important advances like
high-throughput cell physiology and how
high throughput anatomy these advances
were made so quickly that we were able
to begin the mouth cell census project
earlier that we had had anticipated in
those grants as I said it's already been
given out with 250 million dollars to be
spent over five fiscal years from fiscal
year 17 to fiscal year 21 and we hope to
have at the end of that a complete human
a complete Mouse census and while that
is happening we will be ramping up as
shown in the red line funding for human
and non-human primate cell census
efforts as the technologies mature and
as we gain the knowledge from the mouse
projects about how to proceed with these
larger projects so the brain initiative
cell census network is really a flagship
product of the brain initiative that
that has two important aspects to it
that I want to emphasize first it
demonstrates how a concerted focus on
technology early in the course of a an
effort to understand the brain can yield
tremendous benefits we were able to ramp
up the Mouse cell census project much
much more rapidly than we had
anticipated because the technology
developed so quickly and so then enabled
us to take advantage of these changes of
technology in technology and achieve
what we I think is a tremendously
ambitious set of goals the other aspect
of the project that is important to
emphasize that represents what we're
trying to do really brain initiative
wide is create technologies and
resources that the entire community can
use so at the conclusion of the mouse
cell census project there will be an
open source atlas of cell types for the
mouse brain how much information it has
that depends upon the success of the
project but it will be available for all
investigators to use and we're really
enriched neuroscience broadly so
creating these tools and technologies
and doing it ambitiously and with a
focus initially on technology a second
focus on exploiting them this is
dissident this is a success that we hope
to replicate in other areas of the brain
initiative and that's why I wanted to
focus on the brain initiative cell
census Network for a time there's lots
of other investigators in the brain
initiative funded by the brain
initiative who have done really amazing
things and one area where there's also
been tremendous advancement is in the
area of cell and circuit tools that are
aimed as opposed to defining cell types
aimed at understanding their function
one example of that is illustrated here
it's a microscope or actually a dual
microscope that allows simultaneous wide
field imaging and narrow field imaging
in mice and in organ in lower organisms
that allow one to capture both broad
activity throughout
in the map case that mounts the surface
of the brain as well as narrow activity
within a specific brain region to look
at the relationships between activity
powders of single neurons with activity
at scale across the entire brain and
these are the kinds of technologies that
will allow us to really understand the
coordination of neural activity across
broad swaths of brain and understand how
circuits integrate into largest neural
systems mmm these images I wanted to
show you some pretty videos from them
but I guess they didn't carry over so
we'll skip over to the next one I
mentioned of course that there is a big
focus from the brain initiative on human
neural imaging and on developing novel
techniques to modulate activity within
the human brain and although our focus
is on basic science and although our
focus is on technology development this
human component is important because as
quickly as we can we want to try to
allow for the translation of these
technologies into clinical clinically
relevant projects so the brain
initiative is supported next generating
next-generation humans in human imaging
technologies that promise to give us
better and faster pictures of human
brain activity we need to understand the
actual foundations of activity that is
determined by current methods for human
imaging so that we can improve upon
those methods and perhaps more
importantly develop novel methods of
capturing that activity so we've funded
studies that seek to understand the
relationship between neural activity
measured electrically at the level of
single neurons and at the level of local
field potentials with the activity that
is simultaneously a change Eve with
non-invasive methods we also seek to
improve our ability to conduct
non-invasive neuromodulation to look
beyond the current technologies at new
technologies that might be able to
modulate neural activity I mentioned
ultrasound before that we have a
significant investment with several
groups carrying out
experiments to try to refine ultrasound
based neuromodulatory technologies and
an important events that's already
making clinical progress we're
supporting the generation of neck the
next we're supporting I should say the
development of the next generation of
deep brain stimulation devices for a
range of disorders including pain
including depression and including
control of non-essential a sort of
benign essential tremor and they're in a
really remarkable series of experiments
brain initiative and funded
investigators have developed a device
that can monitor neural activity in the
motor system to determine when an
individual is making a movement in in
brain and benign essential tremor the
tremor is not present at rest it's only
present when an individual is making
intentional movement and these devices
can record activity determine with an
algorithm when that individual is about
to make a movement and then turn on the
stimulation that reduces the tremor when
and only when the individual is going to
have that tremor that is when is when
that individual is going to make a and
is a an intentional movement these
devices are already been implanted in a
handful of patients and really are
working quite well and this is important
for several reasons number one that the
constant stimulation that's present in
these devices does cause side effects so
obviously if you only have the
stimulation running when you need it
then the side effects are reduced it
also improves the battery life of the
device and of course changing out the
battery requires a surgical procedure a
minor one but a surgical procedure
nonetheless and it also serves these
record and stimulate devices these
closed-loop devices serve it as an early
example of the potential successes that
one gets when one uses the information
that one can gain from recording from
the brain to help customize clinical
treatment for patients and as I said
before studies
are underway in depression and in
Parkinson's supported by the brain
initiative both at the NIH and other
federal partners to try to use
closed-loop stimulation and/or precision
medicine determined by recordings from
these deep brain electrodes to design
brain stimulation parameters that will
help the patient better and make
efficient use of the technology not
surprisingly the investigators supported
by the brain initiative have been making
such wonderful discoveries that they've
been recognized by a number of awards
and accolades most recently the National
Academy of Sciences recognized three of
our brain investigators reaching low of
Stanford when the purdell research award
Xiao chuan of Harvard won the National
Academy of Sciences award for scientific
discovery and even martyr Brandeis
University won the National Academy of
Sciences award in the neurosciences
these awards were given for the
expertise that makes these individuals
great brain investigators so leach and
lo for addressing how serotonin
modulates diverse physiological
functions and behaviors using viral and
genetic tools shalosh wong for for the
efforts in super-resolution imaging and
single molecular imaging and genome
scale imaging that we are helping us
create that spatial atlas cell census
and cell atlas of the mouse brain and
Eve martyr for understanding
flexibilities to building neuronal
microcircuits and Eve is a member of the
multi council working group for the
brain initiative that's the group that
has been advising the Institute
directors and dr. Crower chefs and I on
on the the grants that we give out and
the funding opportunity announcements
that we that we that we provide to the
community the brain initiative is not
just about the technologies and the
science the brain initiative is also
develop about developing the next
generation
Oh scientists and in some ways the brain
initiative has been tremendously
successful at the level of diversity of
ensuring their scientific workforce has
diversity but only in some limited areas
and particularly those areas are where
we've been successful are in bringing
engineers computer computational
scientists and mathematicians and others
into the neuroscience sphere bringing
their expertise to bear on neuroscience
questions and we admittedly have been
less successful at ensuring the ethnic
and gender diversity and racial
diversity of our investigators and so
we've begun a series about reach efforts
to try to enhance the diversity of
investigators interested in these
cutting-edge projects in neuroscience
led by dr. Michele Jones the National
interneural object disease and stroke we
begun efforts to reach out to minority
students to encourage them participate
these include presentations at the
annual biomedical research conference
for minority students and upcoming
presentations at various societies
including the site for Women's Engineers
Society for advancement Chicano San
Hispanics and Native Americans in
science and other societies to try to
encourage to inform and encourage these
students to take advantage of the
opportunities that brain initiative
offers as I mentioned at the beginning
of the talk we recognize that as we
approach the halfway point in brain 2025
we need to examine what we've done and
think about how we can improve upon that
and also need to really begin planning
for this second five years which is
meant to emphasize discovery trivets
science as opposed to technology
development so dr. Collins recruited a
new advisory group to look at the brain
2025 report and try to figure out what
we've learned so far that we can build
upon more aggressively where
we haven't made such great progress and
where there are new opportunities given
the technologies that we should
investigate beyond what was envisioned
five years ago this effort has been led
by two outstanding neuroscientists
who've been involved in the brain
initiative for a long time dr. John
Ansel and dr. Catherine du Lac the group
convened just under a year ago at the
brain p.i meeting that's the meeting of
the brain principal investigators which
occurs once a year when we celebrated
the fifth anniversary of the launch of
the initiative and announced the
creation of this working group and this
workgroup is actively deliberating how
to how to revise the 2025 report and
also with a subgroup of that workgroup
to examine how to expand the neural
ethics efforts and make sure that these
neurotics efforts and investments are
solidly covering the various areas the
brain initiative the overall workgroup
had an aggressive timeline as I said it
was convenient April of 2018 with a
public town hall at that brain principal
investigators meeting shortly afterwards
the workgroup began having a series of
teleconferences amongst themselves and
planning out outreach efforts that they
would do in the summer of the NIH put
out a request for information to the
neuroscience community asking for input
on brain 2025 on what on what new things
should be included on what we've been
successful about and what what areas we
might go into over the course of the
summer of last year and the fall of last
year we began a series of country were
wide workshops they were I think there
here seem that sorry had a problem with
my screen here there it goes
in August of September and October in
Boston in Chicago and in Houston and
each of those workshops focused on a
different aspect of the brain initiative
then in the fall of 2008 at the Society
for Neuroscience meeting we have a
second Town Hall a larger one attended
by literally you know hundreds of people
at the Society for Neuroscience or the
opportunity to give input and in
December a preliminary report an interim
update of the workgroup was given to the
Advisory Council for the director with a
series of high-level review items based
on that feedback the committee is now
engaged in writing a draft of their
recommendations which will be released
for public comment and the plan for that
will be to finalize a revised strategic
plan that will be submitted this summer
in anticipation of being able to prepare
funding opportunity announcements that
are responsive to that strategic plan
for the fiscal for the next fiscal year
for 2020 and beyond so that's the plan
of the workgroup and they are hard at
work and we're really pleased with the
progress they've been making as I
mentioned as part and parcel of that
workgroup a section of it is focused on
neural ethics in the meantime though
we've not been idle the brain initiative
has had a the multi council working
group which the Advisory Council for the
brain initiative has had a neuroethics
subgroup as well and they've been
they've helped us issue a series of
guiding principles for new ethics this
has been published in the literature in
the Journal of Neuroscience detailing
the focus on on safety in terms of
developing these technologies for human
beings ensuring that these technologies
are monitored and and that ethical
issues are dealt with particularly those
that relate to capacity autonomy and
agency that we protect and provide and
provide confidentiality for neural data
that is shared through the brain
initiative networks through the brain
initiative databases
that and that we think about the
potential malign uses of the
neuroscience tools and neuro
technologies to guard against them that
we move tools and technologies from
research into medical sorry that that
caution should be taken
we at the NIH focus on using these tools
and technologies to improve function in
disease and that we believe that should
be the focus for the brain initiative
moving forward in that any moving of
these use of these tools and
technologies into non-medical uses
should be with caution and into medical
uses should be with an eye towards
ensuring equity and and other ethical
principles as I mentioned before
capacity autonomy and agency we also
need to ensure that we continue to
identify and address the concerns of the
public about the brain initiative and
brain technologies as they arise and
that means encouraging public education
and dialogue and that we should ensure
that the technologies that are developed
and their clinical applications that are
developed through the brain initiative
that they are shared justly and
equitably of course neuroethics is not
just an issue for the US brain
initiative it's really a global issue
and so we have participated in a annual
global neural ethics summit that was
convened first in 2017 and then again in
the fall of 2018 with an eye to ensure
harmonization of Neurath across the
various brain and neuroscience
initiatives that are taking from around
the world we've also been collaborating
with those various brain initiatives in
the form of a group called the
International brain initiative that was
convened by the Cavaliers who has been a
big supporter of the brain initiative
since its inception or the Kombi
foundation I should say there are two
main efforts that we've been involved
with to date which refers says that
neuroethics effort and the second is an
inventory of global brain projects that
has been carrying out under the auspices
of the cowboy
Foundation to try to understand and
describe what the various national brain
initiatives and brain projects are
focused on as a stepping stone to
building out other aspects of the
International brain initiative including
assisting international dissemination in
tools and technologies development of
international data standards and
ensuring did sharing across
international boundaries communication
and outreach and education and training
in each of those areas is currently in
what we call the scoping phase we're
exploring them with our colleagues
around the world finally as I approach
the close of my presentation I wanted to
make sure that everyone listening in is
aware of next month's brain principal
investigators meeting taking place April
11th through 13th at the Marriott
guardman Park here in Washington DC if
you're interested in gaining information
and registering please you can click the
link here or copy it down we have some
really exciting keynote speakers both
brain initiative investigators and
others and it's an international group
so we have Paola our Lata from Harvard
University who works on organoids and
other IPS C Line derived technologies
but also participates in the cell census
Network projects edvard moser from the
Kathleen sue for Neuroscience who of
course is a Nobel Prize winner and
focuses on
hippocampal circuits and internal
circuits and their role in encoding
spatial information Patricia Patricia
Churchland of the University California
who is a well-known philosopher of
neuroscience and has dealt with many
thorny or issues such as agency of that
are brought up by the no ethical issues
in technology and and Marcus Meister
from Caltech who is a pioneer in
developing novel technologies to
[Music]
to monitor and manipulate brain activity
so it's really been quite an adventure
participating in this brain initiative
our efforts to mapping to map brain
activity at the speed of thought to
ensure that we have the best
technologies is really going full-speed
and I'm happy to answer any questions
that you might have thank you thank you
dr. Gordon for that outstanding
presentation we will not be in the live
Q&A portion of this presentation as a
reminder please submit your questions
for dr. Gordon by clicking on the ask a
question box on the far left of your
screen we will address as many questions
as time allows for so we do have a few
questions here that I'd like to share
with you dr. Gordon the first came from
C it says that how much support do you
anticipate grants allocating for
non-human models specifically zebrafish
which are extremely cost and time
effective for experiments very similar
to Roden capabilities that's a very good
question I emphasized in much of the
work that I showed the mammalian aspects
of the brain initiative but we have a
number of projects that support for
example whole brain imaging and
zebrafish and in flies particularly
those that are focused on simultaneous
imaging of entire circuits and behaviors
the question asked about funding levels
and it's important to recognize that we
don't have preconceived notions about
how much money should be spent on any
one organism or any one circuit we look
for scientific opportunities as they
arise the goals of the brain initiative
are to enable the eventual monitoring
and manipulation of circuits in the
human being because we and neuroscience
are generally focused on trying to
understand how
is that we think it produced behavior
but we recognize that a number of range
of different models are necessary to
answer the questions that will
eventually get us that knowledge about
how and why we think and zebrafish and
other non mammalian organisms with
complex brains a complex enough to be
able to ask really crucial questions
about how circuits operate they play a
very very important role so we have
funded a number of projects in these
organisms we have another question and a
second question from another attendee
that's related so I will ask you both of
them together sure what what are the
opportunities within the brain
initiative for early career researchers
or not citizens of the US and the second
question is will the brain initiative be
open to beyond us collaborations what
will be the impact of models and
deliverables and their counterparts from
the --use human brain project those are
two great questions you know I'm not a
hundred percent sure for the first
individual about and the non citizen
question where it comes from there are
there is a brain initiative k99 program
that is for underrepresented minorities
and i believe that may be restricted to
you as US citizens but I'm not 100% sure
the general k99 program though is not
restricted to u.s. citizens early stage
investigators and faculty positions who
are not US citizens I shouldn't say not
US citizens are really you have to be
the US citizen or a green card holder
for some of our training programs and
with the exception as a set of the
generic k99 r00 program that applies to
most of our training programs but for
early in the stage investigators who are
faculty there is no restriction as such
and so those are completely available to
two individuals who are not US citizens
and this gets me to the next question
the brain initiative actually has given
grants to international investigators so
the brain stative is empowered to
to grant funds as are all the
Institute's to investigators in other
countries that are answering the
questions that that need to be answered
where they're the best situated to
answer those questions or in the case of
the brain initiative to develop those
technologies we do also support a number
of collaborations that cross national
boundaries and some of those do involve
investigators who are also engaged in
the in the in Europe's human brain
project so I would say there's a lot of
synergy in terms of the the grants that
were funded and of course there's a lot
of synergy intellectually the European
efforts focus on models of the brain on
computational models is very very
complementary to our efforts to try to
use those computational models to
address circuit level functioning so
know that there's a lot of crosstalk and
we anticipate that only increasing in
the future thank you for that we have
another question the brain atlas sounds
amazing
you said phase 1 is already complete
when do you project it will be available
for us to see and is it analogous to the
3d human brain coming out of Uli's in
Germany yeah so I would say it's
analogous but it's good it'll be we hope
much much richer in terms of the data
that is included although that that
effort is a really important one that
has made that is really wonderful
contribution
it's similarly analogous to the Allen
Brain atlas that exists already that
describes expression of for example of
proteins and RNAs throughout the brain
and and has a lot of anatomical data as
well but what we really hope to achieve
is it neuron by neuron Atlas some of the
data is becoming available already or
will be shared shortly the full project
will be complete in 2021 and I'm not
exactly sure when you'll have a usable
3d atlas in that timeframe but the hope
is by 2021 it will be available but the
data behind it are being made publicly
available on a more aggressive time
scale
thank you we have another question you
can that you are now allowed to and even
required to share all the data that
comes into the research from the brain
initiative how will you be able to
handle the tremendous amount of data
that will arise from that research and
process it in a coherent manner well
it's a challenge I'm not gonna lie we've
put out really the data sharing
infrastructure is something that needs
to be built so at the NIH and at my own
Institute the National Institute of
Mental Health we've developed data
infrastructures that can handle very
large datasets really petabytes size or
hundreds of terabytes size datasets from
human neuroimaging so we have developed
the capacity to share very large
datasets and to store them the brain
initiative datasets that will come in
because they are activity over time are
going to be perhaps an order of
magnitude larger and more challenging to
share but as I said the the in the
branch just to begin developing not just
the not just the software infrastructure
but also the protocols the standards and
and the methods frankly are all have all
been awarded or the first layer of them
I should say have been awarded and we
hope within the next year or two to be
able to stand up some of those
structures and facilitate some of those
protocols
I should mention though that one
important aspect of this sharing
opportunity is the is the fact that
you're probably gonna have to do your
data analysis on these large data sets
in the cloud the data sets now are
getting too large to download that's
already true for some of our larger
human neuroimaging data sets like the
adolescent brain and cognitive
development study where we can't
download it that too big you have to if
you want them brought in you have to pay
for a hard drive
to be shipped to you so with these brain
datasets we imagine even more
importantly a cloud computing is going
to be the way to go okay great I'm just
gonna bring up one more quick question
because I think this is extremely
important given the mental health crisis
that we're facing if you don't mind we
only have a few more minutes have have
the fruits of research from the brain
initiative contributed to our
understanding or opioid dependence and
potential ways to overcome it I think
we're at the early days of contributions
of the brain initiative in that area we
as I said we did put out a notice saying
that we want to be able to use brain
brain initiative technologies to study
the neural circuits and engage in pain
and and and of course that will also
influence our understanding of how the
brain circuits are affected by o pious
the nationals to deter ugh abuse has a
number of projects in that area and they
have a number of investigators who are
night of funded who are engaged in the
brain initiative developing the
technologies to improve our ability to
study it so I would hope that we would
have some answers in that realm in the
near future okay great thank you very
much but there was a question also if
this presentation of yours will be
available later on by attendee Chris I
just wanted to let him and the others
know that this talk will be available on
demand for the next three months so for
anyone who came in part way through dr.
Gordon's talk it's still available -
thank you again dr. Gordon and thank you
to our wonderful audience today for your
incredible questions any questions that
were not answered and will be followed
up by our speaker via email coming up
next
dr. Juna and dr. Karen David will be
discussing NIH brain funding
opportunities specifically the NIH brain
initiative and launching human
neuroscience to see their